es sind bilder wie wir sie sonst nur aus
dem amerikanischen fernsehen kennen ein
polizeihubschrauber verfolgt einen raser
im südosten berlins und gibt die
fahrstrecke an insgesamt zwölf
streifenwagen weiter die den fahrer
verfolgen als der mann den hubschrauber
bemerkt verliert die nerven in der
wuhlheide prallte das auto gegen einen
lichtmast und für die flucht mahmud
hatte keinen führerschein
da hat der betreffende fahrzeugführer in
einem wohngebiet straßen in köpenick 12
einsatzfahrzeuge der berliner polizei
genau
er hatte mal wieder finden geschlagen
waghalsigsten fahrmanövern man kaum
nachvollziehen und kaum beschreiben kann
hat er sich dem zugriff immer wieder
entziehen können ist dann polizeisperren
über einen gehweg umfahren usw sogar
wirklich insgesamt 28 minuten lang
klinik gerast links und rechts und fast
schon nach oben abgebogen ist ein
gruseliges video eigentlich wie jemand
so so
rücksichtslos sich vor der polizei
entfernen wollte
doch bevor er vor gericht gestellt
werden konnte wurde mahmud ermordet
berlin ist die hauptstadt der raser im
vergangenen jahr lag die anzahl der
verbotenen kfz rennen bei knapp unter
900 bis oktober 2021 zählten die
behörden bereits
982 ermittlungsverfahren ja es gibt ein
ganz klassisches täterprofil sind junge
männer zwischen 18 und 30 jahren in
dieser spanne 18 bis 30 jahren sind es
dann noch mal die 21 bis 25 jahren die
überproportional häufig in erscheinung
treten frauen sind relativ selten dabei
der anteil weiblicher beschuldigter
liegt nur drei prozent etwa wir haben 97
prozent
sowie murat b am 26 dezember 2020 war er
in seinem bmw auf dem kudamm
zielgerichtet auf der suche nach einem
anderen nasa den er auch fand bei über
100 sachen in einer tempo-30-zone
verliert nur ab die kontrolle über
seinen bmw auf der bülowstraße in
schöneberg begeht er einen fahrfehler
schleuderte in einen baucontainer und
dann in drei geparkten autos
seine strafe als sozialhilfeempfänger
zahl der 80 tagessätze á 30 euro und er
muss für insgesamt 16 monate auf seinen
führerschein verzichten
die auswertung des bordcomputers ergab
dass der bmw mit über 100 sachen in der
tempo-30-zone die kontrolle verloren hat
und genau an dieser stelle hier rammte
ja mehrere parkende autos und sein
beifahrer wurde schwer verletzt zur
überführung der täter nutzt die
amtsanwaltschaft die elektronische black
box der boliden den event data recorder
fdr auf dem werden alle motordaten fünf
sekunden vor dem aufprall und auslösen
des airbags aufgezeichnet drehzahl
geschwindigkeit bremsverhalten es keine
unmittelbaren tatzeugen gibt greifen wir
auf digitale fahrzeugdaten zurück als
beispiel habe ich hier ein airbag
steuergerät in diesem werk steuergerät
ist ein amerikanischer kraftfahrzeug
sicherheitsstandard verbaut dr
bei der airbag auslösung wie in den
letzten fünfzehn grünen der vaart
dokumentiert rat volk angezeigte
fahrgeschwindigkeit also die
geschwindigkeit
wie tief ist ins gaspedal getreten
worden und wann und ob ausgebremst
worden
dass sich herstellungs gelände der
berliner polizei hier in berlin
mahlsdorf hier landen die meisten der
1200 sichergestellten fahrzeuge meistens
wegen illegaler autorennen hier warten
die ps boliden auf ihre untersuchung
und hier stehen die ps-boliden sie
warten darauf dass die technik hat der
autohersteller hierher kommen um sie zu
untersuchungen sie sind auf die
bordcomputer aus die sogenannten black
boxen die alle wichtigen technischen
daten aufgezeichnet haben die dann die
raser überführen werden
zu schnell für die polizei war auch
heilige aus neukölln er soll am 29
oktober 2020 um 10 uhr 45 bei einer
wilden verfolgungsjagd quer durch
kreuzberg der polizei in schöneberg
entkommen seien der drei zentner mann
besitzt keinen führerschein saß schon
über vier jahre im knast für dieses
letzte autorennen bekam zwei weitere
jahre haft
was machen die ermittler wenn ihnen
einen raser durch die lappen geht wir
haben dann aber noch verschiedene andere
mittel und wege wie wir versuchen den
täter zu stellen wir beschlagnahmen die
fahrzeuge schauen nach durch die polizei
schaut nach fingerabdruck spuren ist der
airbag ausgelöst sind auch auf dem
ausgelösten airbag in die nach spuren
um festzustellen in aller regel dass wir
da über einen dna-vergleich versuchen
die täterschaft festzustellen wir
schauen ihnen die radio navigations
motoren der fahrzeuge welches handy hat
sich eingeloggt in die
kommunikationseinheit des fahrzeuges und
über die telefonnummer möglicherweise
rückschlüsse auf die täterschaft zu
erlangen wir schauen uns die videos
genau an den einzelbildern der gabe ob
man den betroffenen fahrzeugführer
wiedererkennen kann die amtsanwaltschaft
setzt bei der bekämpfung der raser
kriminalität auf ein neues gesetz
berlins justizsenatorin einen
überlassungsvertrag fahrzeuge mit über
200 ps für personen unter 25 jahren
durchsetzen denn 80 prozent der raser
autos sind mietwagen
bei uns im studio unser bild
chefreporter matthias becker schön dass
sogar bis matthias wir haben dich auch
gerade schon im beitrag gesehen du
kennst dich aus in der raser szene bist
auch vertraut mit all diesen fällen die
wir gerade gezeigt um interessante zahl
lasst uns erst mal darüber sprechen es
wurde gesagt in unserem beitrag raser
sind 97 prozent männer und nur drei
prozent frauen
und jetzt ist es tatsächlich so morgen
startet hier in berlin ein prozess da
geht es um eine weibliche raserin das
heißt mehr dazu ja also auch wenn es nur
drei prozent sind sie stehen der
männlichen konkurrenz in nichts nach
auch in der gefahrenen geschwindigkeit
mit den waghalsigen bis zu
kriminellen handlungen die sie machen
morgen ist eine ganz bekannte
tätowiererin vor gericht raser p 42
jahre sie es mit ihrem bmw oder soll mit
ihrem bmw über die autobahn wo tempo 60
es bergab mit über 150 km/h grasheim in
ihrem bmw und ein an fahrender lkw
kleintransporter folie da konnte sie gar
nicht mehr anhalten gehen hat sich
erstmal von der straße gerammt und hat
selber sich und ihre insassen und auch
den lkw fahrer verloren bei der
anzeigenaufnahme haben die beamten ganz
schnell festgestellt da liegt alkohol in
der atemluft und dann hat sie gepostet
und sie soll weit über 1,4 promille
gehabt hatten wahnsinn weißt du was ich
mich frage ist das so eine
kurzschlusshandlung eigentlich in den
meisten fällen oder ist es gezielt dass
ich los war und sagt heute bin ich auf
so ein raise aus
muss da unterscheiden also bei den
erlebnisorientierten jungen männern sind
es schon die die die kräfte messen
wollen wie zeigen wollen dieses den
habitus ausnehmen bei frauen ist es ja
anders da ergibt sich dass spontan oder
auch ein bisschen alkohol der intent
wird dass sie denn doch mal ganz gerne
auch mal runter drücken um mal zu zeigen
was da so geht was muss passieren deiner
meinung nach wir hatten auch grad schon
im beitrag das thema überlassungsvertrag
max uns noch mal ganz kurz erklären und
ist das nur in berlin geplant oder auch
in anderen städten und ländern naja
berlin ist da der vorreiter der
justizsenator er möchte das gerne
verbieten also unter 25 insbesondere
natürlich auch zielgerichtet für die
autovermietung weil an die kommt dann
die polizei nicht ran auch die
amtsanwaltschaft darf diese autos nicht
einziehen weil sie ja ich sag mal nicht
im besitz und dem eigentum der raser
gehören und die müssen immer wieder
herausgegeben werden also tut es den
rasern auch nicht sonderlich weh und da
wird er an und er will ihm keine
unter 25 jährigen die mit einem auto mit
über 200 ps fahren und damit wäre berlin
der vorreiter und wenn es mal schule
macht dann sind die länder natürlich
alles schnell dabei das muss noch
passieren dann hat sie das gefühl die
polizei ist machtlos
na ja es kommt noch was ganz
interessantes sagte mir der us-anleihen
am ersten juli 2022 wird eu weit ein
neues gesetz eingeführt werden da kommen
dass wir auch gehört haben der rekord
dar da diese blackbox zur verpflichtung
für die autoindustrie in jedes neue
fahrzeug mit rein und dabei ist es auch
unerheblich ob ich einen ein clio fahrer
oder oder oder einem ps boliden von bmw
habe entscheidend ist die maximale
erreichte geschwindigkeit drückt der
cleo das gaspedal runter zeigt der data
and die 100 prozent an und dann bist du
bei dieser straftat lass uns noch mal
ganz kurz über den neuen bußgeldkatalog
sprechen auch nicht unwichtig im
zusammenhang mit der raser szene es wird
also jetzt auch teurer man muss nicht
mal rasen selbst 10 15 km h schneller
das ist schon eine saftige geldstrafe
meinst du das brennt die raser im
wahrsten sinne des wortes aus nein die
raser interessiert es nicht die raser
haben größtenteils auch selber schon gar
keine führerscheine mehr trotz dem rasen
sie und trotzdem fahren die autos mit
falschen kennzeichen die auch immer für
die ist das gesetz nicht gemacht es soll
ja auch eigentlich dieser verschärfung
des bußgeldes fußgänger und radfahrer
geschützt werden ja und da geht es nicht
um die raser szene selbst
also das heißt wo liegt noch die
motivation solche raser ja das ist der
habitus sich messen wohin kräftemessen
ich bin besser als du das sind die so
fast and furious
szenen die wir täglich in berlin haben
täglich vielen dank herr matthias becker
für diese interessanten einblicke heute
[Musik]
komm zurück
naja ich beantworte
in der kita biberburg und
[Musik]
da haben wir gleich mal in fahrt
ja ihr leben lang und kräftig
[Musik]